ah the main batteries are shut down
we're stuck out here
[Music]
you have one bullet against an entire
army
what can you do on your own i told you
[Music]
it's enough
so i see
you work on the batteries
i'll buy us some time
i don't believe it
you made it
now what
we can't go anywhere while that status
beam is active
then we shut it down
stasis beam weapons
all of it
how will you get back
i'll figure something out
eliminate all survivors
eliminate
chief
whatever you're planning to do do it
fast
it's
[Music]
come on
[Music]
so
hmm
uh
lay down our lives to protect our creed
[Music]
atriox showed us the way
together
we
are
that's hologram
he led the attack on the infinity
he was looking for something
he
he killed everyone i know
we met
[Music]
his actions
we are his legacy
oh
fight
together
lay down
prepare for the appointment
foreign
damaged
immediately
[Music]
oh
drop ships
an invasion force
how do we stand a chance against all
these
the banished one already
we could be the only two humans left
alive out here
then there's still hope
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
acknowledged we're on the move the rest
of you spartans if you're not already
off the affinity disengage and get to
the lifeboats asap
wait for one we got a lot of personnel
on routes to say to halo what are you
seeing out there
i'll see you on the ground spartans
[Music]
foreign
uh
[Music]
protect me
stop this
[Music]
ah
[Music]
club
[Music]
no
[Music]
we're in trouble
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he fights
foreign
is
stay
[Music]
your approaches
soon
the banished will stand victorious
[Music]
patriarchs
hear these words
even from beyond this life
your will is served
your forces occupy the rain
within ours it will be under our control
humanity will cower before your legacy
[Music]
they
will burn
their praise and defiance
will be all
but a memory
[Music]
we
we need to get out of here i'm working
on it
work faster these pelicans nearly on
board and the power's still out
[Music]
this is
what
stand down
oh
already
uh
it's locked down requires a hack
okay
and you can do that no
new plan
scuttle the ship
you're going to destroy this ship
with us in it
i'm going to die here
there are cooling pipes running towards
the main engines
so
i'm going to warm things up
he's hiding again
the little things all waiting
don't let them get me please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
get ready
okay okay
fire up those engines chief
maybe we'll survive
[Music]
report
a spartan
know
something better
the master chief returns
we thought you did
tossed into the void
yet here you stand
[Music]
humans call you their savior
covenant
demon
the banished
train
destroy this craft if you must
it matters not
the banished will hunt you down
pursue you
wherever you run
[Music]
who is that
do you know him
no
well he knows you
he knows all about you
you need to hurry get back here
i don't know how long this ship will
hold together
is
destroy
wow
do you think
[Music]
is
what was it he felt
bad
even the vanish seemed freaky
we are running out of time
the batteries
charging slowly
i don't know it's gonna be close
too close
oh
is
okay so 90 seconds to your full charge i
hope this place holds together that long
charge faster
[Music]
[Music]
oh
come on
[Music]
you